hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today we're hopping back on
monster on our world again and we're
gonna be talking about Diablos and it's
specific how to defeat him while solo
obviously not everybody can cue into a
match together with a bunch of friends
some people have to play alone and
that's completely fine I have this guide
perfectly strategized and in-depth on
how to defeat Diablos while playing solo
so let's get right into it so first off
Diablos is a dragon he's gonna be found
in the wild spire wastes usually at the
top right of the map and he's either
going to be underground or on the
surface I happen to be finding him
underground I'm not entirely sure but
you will find him but that is where I
found him going off of the psychology
report which you can receive from my
monster once you reach level 1 with his
research it says Diablos is weak on the
head wings in the stomach slash
underbelly now depending on the type of
weapon you wield you do more damage in
certain spots blunt weapons like hammers
are gonna be good for aiming at the head
SARP slash e type weapons like the dual
blades and the worker blade and such
you'll want to aim for the underbelly
and range weapons you should focus on
shooting at the wings also the horns and
back are breakable and the tail has the
possibility to be severed off if enough
damage is dealt to it on the right side
of the screen you're going to be seeing
a thing that says ailments and elements
melee weapon users should pay attention
to the elements tab ailments are more
focused toward ranged weapon users going
off the report for the elements in
Diablos is weak to ice the most with
dragon and water being the next best
thing and he's also weak to paralysis
with everything but stun being the next
best choice if you have a ranged weapon
next up is the rewards you can also
unlock this tab if you get ranked 2 for
research on any type of specific monster
and going off to what the report says
Diablo C's Ridge is a droppable material
Diablo says marrow it only spawns when
the back is broken
twisted Horner's for when the horns are
broken and tail cases if you happen to
sever the tail and carve it when it
drops on the right side you're gonna be
seeing carves and rewards cards for what
happens it'll have a chance of spawning
when you carve Diablos dead body and the
reward is the mission rewards received
when finishing a request or expedition
he has been slain in it at the beginning
of the quest you're gonna be receiving
in your item box some ez screamer pods
these will come and hand you later in
the fight so definitely grab these the
setup I recommend using for solo players
is mega potions flash pods some steak or
ez rations will do it for some extra
stamina of course
and the screamer pods I also like to use
the vitality mantle as as well I'm also
unaware of how to get this mental I
randomly talked to the fireteam leader
back in astera and he happened to give
me it I'm not entirely sure if he needed
to do a quest or if you had to kill a
specific monster go through the story
mode but I was given the vitality mantle
from him
this basically negates all damage up to
a certain threshold basically bit
basically meaning you will take no
damage but it slowly wear and tears the
mantle until it's unable to be used
it's got like a three minute basic like
recharge rate so it is very useful but
when it's gone it takes a very long time
to get back your palico doesn't really
need much in terms of his equipment I
obviously went for the standard vigor
while with vigor wasps since it is an
extra source of healing it's always nice
now Diablos is very big but don't let
that overwhelm you yes he will hit you
very hard but use the flash flies in the
very first area in the underground area
to stun him and get some extra damage
really quick in the fight and I cannot
stress this enough guys and do this with
every fight you do take it as slow as
possible you have 50 minutes and you
only have three faints so be very
careful watch his moves and take it slow
I would hate for you guys to be done to
be dead almost about to kill him and
then you faint and you have to do this
all over again that would be horrible
one of the ah blows is most devastating
moves is his tremor move he'll go
underground and dig under you and
explode through the surface and uppercut
you in the air for a bit
this move is easily noticeable because
the only move he does where he goes
underground and you can dodge it by
noticing as soon as he digs sprint and
jump away if he's near you sprint jump
has an incredible amount of
invincibility frames so so much so that
just like in this clip you can
preemptively jump and land before he
even does the move and still not get hit
so definitely use this as a tactic you
can also use the screamer pods we talked
about earlier to force him to come up to
the surface which you noticed which was
in the cutscene when you do the quest to
actually defeat Diablo he also has other
close-range attacks like a tail pounder
if you're behind him a bite if you're in
front of him or a charge if you're
within a medium distance of him you can
bait Diablos charge and cause him to run
into wild spires and get caught which
will give me some free hits as well all
of these moves are incredibly easy to
learn the timings of it just takes a
little bit of practice in the next area
you'll be surrounded by some sand falls
don't worry about it
it's nothing to be worried about Diablos
will go inside of those and dig
underground and do his tremor attack
like we talked about there really isn't
much to help you in assist you in here
so dodge the moves you mentioned earlier
use flash or screamer pods when
necessary and you should be completely
fine if he runs away again he should be
going into the third area which is what
I like to call the rocky plains you can
use this area to lay traps preemptively
if you have some ore mountain for some
extra damage as well just make sure that
when you finish mounting him you attack
in the spot that we mentioned earlier
depending on what type of weapon you
used with a sharp blunt or a range
weapon once Diablo starts limping you
know you're almost done eventually he
will try to fall asleep and rest up I
like to use this time to plant two
really big bombs and a very tiny one
with a timer and if hit in the right
spot you should do about a hundred to
two hundred damage and then proceed from
there to rinse and repeat until he's
eventually slain and there you go now
you know how to defeat the AH blows hope
you guys found this information helpful
I plan on doing other solo guides for
the other monsters like Rathalos and any
others further in the story mode that I
have yet to discover yet if you guys did
enjoy please sure to give it a like
subscribe if you're new I cover a lot of
the Monster Hunter content I'm gonna be
doing a lot more since this game has
been released I'm gonna be doing guides
on most of the characters and other
little tips and then probably start
covering some news if there's some
future updates in the future so
definitely be sure to stay for that my
two most recent videos are going to be
popping up on screen a monster hundred
the first one's gonna be about 5 tips
for beginners if you're new to the game
and how to mount it like we talked about
earlier mounting is an incredible thing
that you should learn how to do it's
very useful and especially in this
Diablo sleight is very useful so if you
do have the time go check out these two
videos if you want and with that guys
hope you have a great rest of your day
and peace out